[Music]
he picks me up by my throat all the way
up to the ceiling now I know you had to
clarify that wasn't ceiling because I
hear you were getting some fan backlash
will it be revealed on the show yes it
will be on the show for sure um I can't
say that I can't necessarily give the
person you know the name out right now
but I did get the healing that I needed
like that was something that was always
just in the back of my mind a big
question mark of like why or or like how
that really affected me and so I could I
left marriage boot camp feeling a lot
lighter and I did forgive that person is
that going to be an issue at all that
person being revealed like for your
family as a whole or we yeah I am I
called this person and I told them what
was going on and that kind of thing and
I think they were a little shocked about
it and probably a little heart that it
was mentioned but at the same time like
it needed to happen I needed to forgive
that person and that was not something I
planned to bring out or anything it's
just when you're there you forget
cameras are rolling and you're in
therapy and you're talking about these
things and like you just work through
your issues
[Music]
you